so I I do kind of want to ask you you
know have you here now I keep hearing
this thing bandied around the kind of
that kind of makes me a little bit upset
okay when I hear people being accusing
others of being fake geek know this
topic okay yeah okay I'm sorry too I
don't know overjoyed to discuss okay so
happy to discuss this maybe I've walked
into a minefield it's kind of a
minefield yeah um you know I think it's
silly you know geeks and nerds and
people who who love this kind of content
people who love video games and comic
books and and sci-fi fantasy novels and
all that great stuff we love it because
we're passionate about it and I think to
judge other people who want to get into
that kind of content and keep them out
of it like I don't think that's fair I
think you know if we love it we should
be willing to share it with the rest of
the world well there's yeah there's
almost a defensive exclusivity it's an
extension weirdly of a hipster mentality
oh we were here first right you know
we've got cred we already planted this
flag and if you if we see you as a
newcomer ignoring the fact that you know
for example I was on your your gadget
com profile and you have owned every
nintendo console ever made you know
obviously a creek oh no atari but i'll
take that up come on team Kaliko I I do
actually have fond memories of playing
Cabbage Patch Kazan Kaliko at a friend's
house oh yeah yeah yeah actually I'm
pretty good I'm gonna say a smurf nice
you guys are watching the brand new
video version of the game life podcast
right here on YouTube you should
subscribe I did I'm not hosting this
right I know no it's doing it does yes I
can't do any more shoes subscribe